now thanks to driving you remember it
had three parts to it right FST up one
if it's day three I wanted to review
member what the three parts well we
don't the first two okay
yeah very good the first one was cost of
purchases so what are you go spend it
one actually just get the car and be
able to drive it legally okay number two
we looked at not just getting Akana
but yeah keeping the car so that's
operating cost insurance etc you got the
car keep your car now we want to keep
you alive in the car which is what this
safety part which is last part of
methods ago yes okay so blood alcohol
content incredibly relevant okay no
blood alcohol courts it's actually like
what is it it's a concentration
concentration is like you've got some
liquid right and you put some other
stuff in it and how much of the other
stuff is there okay so the concentration
we're particularly interested obviously
there's alcohol right is the
concentration now we tend to measure
that in Queens so like a mess of alcohol
a massive alcohol versus well alcohol
and look at the name what is it being
compared to how much blood there is
right is the concentration of alcohol in
blood now we would measure blood it's a
capacity like how much plug your body
has so that's in bills okay now just
have a look at this for a second I'm
comparing two quantities one is a mass
and one is a capacity so we have a name
for when we compare two quantities in
the different it's a rate very good
ratios aware it's like we're comparing
two same things right like dollars of
dollars or mils of bills
this is grams and middles okay so this
is basically this is a special rate okay
so when we say concentration all
concentrations are rates of some kind I
just wanted you to have that you know
because everything you know about rates
now you can apply to this okay so when
we say for example
blood alcohol content if I said okay
someone is put in five 0.05 right what
that actually means is you've got zero
point I might write this separately on
the side P 0.05 graves of alcohol right
so that's how much of this stuff is in
your blood um in because like drugs are
very powerful I mean very very small
amounts of them to make very very big
offense right so point zero if I grant
alcohol you could hardly even see that
in a hundred mils of what what's have
your bills
what does a hundred mils look like okay
so like yeah a cop I think a normal like
glass is like 270 mils
I think okay so that's why even half
full so you've got a fairly small amount
of blood tiny tiny amount of alcohol
okay
now you could write this in a couple of
other ways I will say this is weird this
is confusing but because you're doing
0.05 and it's out of them a hundred mils
of blood right sometimes you will see
this as blood alcohol content of 0.05%
pacific at all a hundred right they need
this one hundred okay they don't mean
like if I said to you okay five percent
put that into your calculator that's
0.05 but here in this case these
actually be exactly the same thing
that's a bit mean but I want you to see
it like it doesn't take actually much
alcohol to kill someone see all we can
have very very small numbers that
certainly does it be a bad blood I call
content of like five or something like
that you'd be long dead okay so question
yeah I can't say um that's a really
interesting question
when we think about other I'm gonna show
you some pictures of a second what do
you think about how we consume alcohol
we consume alcohol in liquid form
generally speaking right but what
alcohol is is a particular kind of
molecule it's a substance right you can
distill it out it can drive all that
kind of thing and so even though we
consume it in Mills and lead to more
peripheral leaders in either capacity P
right the actual thing that's changing
you that's having effect on you is this
substance which is measured out in grams
I think part of it as well is to avoid
confusion as you'll see in a minute
between how much you're drinking versus
how much alcohol is actually being
consumed okay because they're quite
different things depending on what
you're drinking so you got a whole bunch
of numbers here by the way 0.05 is not
accidental that number but I want you to
if you have another color with you get
that out even if it's just a highlighter
and there's a single number that I
really want you to have right of the
topic pages big big letters that is the
most important number in this whole
lesson okay because we're gonna get
carried other all kinds of things for
you but zero is important does anyone
know why's your it important in this
topic for L&P plate is no that's your
blood alcohol in it right and you guys
are going to be LNP players for a long
time to code right so the most important
like my moral responsibility is to make
sure you get that number okay and I
should point out one of the tricky
things with this is there's only really
one well practically speaking there's
only one make way to measure accurately
what someone's by blood alcohol content
is anything what it is breathalyzer
that's right obviously you could do it
you could do a blood test but now
they're gonna take that and then they're
gonna send it off to you know
or whatever and a day later you like oh
okay I was four to six it's not a good
way to go breathalyzers yeah okay so
let's have a look at your second even
though I have a full last struggle or a
piripi so my limit is point five but if
I going to go somewhere and then drive
home for me that's my limit now here's
why I remember I said to you there's
only one accurate way to measure someone
thought a phone call tap and that's what
a breathalyzer okay you can make
estimates we can make uh since I'm gonna
talk about other maths of how to make
that estimate but that's all it is it's
just an estimate okay you can never say
oh I'm pretty close to point oh five I'm
sure I'll be all right to drive okay
that's how people get into accidents
okay so this is the important number I
want you to get now just while we're in
the context the reason why I pulled the
pointer five is because it's the legal
limit for a full license rather have a
look at the middle one though you might
not be familiar with that number this
number is long that means is a lower
threshold for how much alcohol you can
take why is this number Laura who is it
referring to truck drivers people with
big responsibilities because they have
eCos containing set like maybe a tanker
or something like that
the tank weather is the thing though if
you if you have a good night out of
Sunday night and you have to turn up to
work on Monday morning is that alcohol
still going to be in your system or not
yeah it is yeah you better believe it is
and that's why we have a link of don't
even go there okay so like I said zero
point two point five by the way you
should just stop making both for
yourself to Google this page um I just
found it by searching New South Wales
blood alcohol they met and this would be
like the first or second I think it's
even a highlighted result because
there's lots of really really helpful
practical information when you go and
have a look down here please go and look
at it just like I told you about like
through prices it like that's just a
practical thing in you know you need to
know this as well